this is what if
and this is what would happen
as jupiter
would swallow every planet in the solar system
Jupiter has already swallowed up its planet
about four comma
five billion years ago
a protoplanet bumped into the young Jupiter
the protoplanet was ten times as massive as the earth
and consisted of rocky and icy material
the core of jupiter broke apart
and closer
material mixed with hydrogen and helium
a few billion years later
the heavy material came together again in the dense core
that we see now
gobble up a single planet
that's one thing
but can jupiter eat all seven of them
in this scenario
you will see the planets from big to small
be swallowed up
although we save the earth for last
jupiter first victim is said to be saturn
from earth you can see these gas giants
like two bright stars
and if you looked at the night sky
while jupiter gobbles up saturn
you would only see jupiter become super clear
but if you were closer to this action
you would see complete chaos
jupiter is only three times as heavy as saturn
so he would sock a planet
which is almost as big
first their moons would collide
creating huge amounts of debris
some moon remnants would rain more on jupiter
and some of the debris would float in space
while jupiter crashed into saturn
would jupiter's oppervlaktetemperatuur get hotter
than the outer layer of the
sun what remains of saturn
would mix with jupiter atmosphere
they would become one
by gobbling up saturn
would be the mass and gravity of jupiter
increase by thirty percent
Jupiter would also be prominent
getting new rings from the shattered mane
then it would be the two
enveloping iron-giant uranus and neptune
the twenty-seven months of uranus
would bump into jupiter's rings
which would increase the floating debris
uranus has an icy core of water
methane and ammonia
but the inner core of neptune is rocky
either way both cores would melt
if the planets collided with jupiter
now jupiter would be almost forty percent heavier
and he would head for his first
rocky planet snacks
the rock planets venus and mars
wouldn't even reach jupiter's core
they would burn up jupiter atmosphere
like they were just asteroids
then we would be our last planetary neighbor
see disappear
in this built-up jupiter
mercury is even smaller than jupiter's largest moon
ganimedes
so he would be driven apart by Jupiter's rings
causing even more debris to come
now only the earth and jupiter would be left
and the earth would be in great trouble
but how would jupiter swallow our planet
even in its normal state
without swallowing six planets
does jupiter gravity affect the earth
every 45000 years
does the appeal of jupiter and venus
wobble the earth's orbit
it causes hotter summers
colder winters and more rain in the tropics
and now the appeal of jupiter
be stronger by more than forty percent
but
jupiter appeal still wouldn't outweigh
against the gravity of the sun
so jupiter should come get the earth
like him all other planets in our solar system
has engulfed
jupiter has no hard surface
like the rocky planets
you could say that jupiter is a big one
dense gas sphere
its surface is defined as the point
where are atmospheric pressure
is equal to that of the earth
can the earth just go through it
uh no
just like the rest of the planets
the earth and all life would be roasted on it
first of all
we would be bombed by asteroids
as we go through the rings of jupiter
i doubt anyone would survive this
but if we survived
they would see the earth ignite
as the jupiter atmosphere enters
jupiter is so massive
Which
even if he were to pick up his seven planetary neighbors
he wouldn't even double a size
what would happen if jupiter kept growing
even if jupiter increased its mass by 400
it would remain about the same size
but the extra mass would close jupiter like this
that he was going to pull himself into himself
it would get smaller instead of bigger
and as a jupiter its mass by seventy thousand percent
would enlarge
could he start a fusion reaction and glow up
like a star
can you imagine what it would be like not to have one
but having two stars in the solar system does
as always that's a story for another what if